so welcome everyone welcome to GCP next
2016 I'm project or product manager in
the cloud networking team at Google in
the Google cloud platform
so let's start with you today you just
saw your CIO on the idea of moving your
workloads to the Google cloud
congratulations yeah you started first
with saying yeah we have on-demand
access to compute you're going to save
tons of money but what really clinched
the deal for you was this Google cloud
platforms world-class infrastructure and
Google cloud platforms best of the breed
cloud services that is why Google cloud
platform gives you the ability to
deliver your services anywhere anytime
across the globe so how does Google
cloud platform deliver your services
reliably right across the globe with
high performance and with low latency a
key cloud service that lets it do this
is Google global load balancing and that
is the focus of my talk today I'm sure
all of you are familiar with load
balancers but maybe let's do a load
balancer 101 now load balancers were
created to deliver high availability and
to scale the services and if you look at
a load balancer as you can see there you
have your backends these are the ones
that actually service your clients you
stick a load balancer in front you put a
front-end whip on it and voila you have
a service where the load is distributed
across all of these servers you have a
service that's resilient because if one
of these fails your load balancer will
seamlessly route the request to another
healthy instance you can scale your
service now because you simply stick
another server there and it scales up
and lastly a load balancer is the one
that hosts your front-end web so one
more thing that I talked about in the
previous one right
it's load balancing 101 now let's look
at it from the point of view of a cloud
provider right look at the cloud you
have a multi-tenant environment
you've thousands of users you've compute
resources that are scattered across the
world and then you need the ability to
seamlessly scale as the number of your
users and the traffic grows so you look
here you see three or four flavors of
load balancing right the first one is
your hardware load balancers think of
them I'm sure all of you have used them
they have fixed form factor so if you
need more throughput what do you do you
go and buy a bigger box if you need more
features what do you do you approach the
vendor and you wait for their release to
put the features in a che is pretty much
active active or active standby and
these are definitely expensive to load
balance at scale especially cloud scale
next come the software load balancers
and when I talk of software load
balancers I mean load balancing logic
that lot runs in a VM instance could be
a cluster right now these are definitely
a step up but is that enough to deliver
cloud scale load balancing that is where
the Google cloud platform global load
balancing comes in
it's basically software-defined globally
distributed load balancing right that is
exactly what Google global load
balancing is and today I wanted to shed
some light on it there's some
interesting aspects about it that I
wanted to highlight so first let's start
with you again why do you want global
application delivery maybe you want to
deliver your services around the globe
maybe you need the highest levels of
well availability so you want to
replicate your services around the globe
or you want to deliver your services
with low latency close to wherever your
users are that is what Google global
load balancing enables you to do
instantiate your workloads anywhere you
want in the globe but unlike traditional
DNS base load balancing solutions you
don't have to front in each region with
a with its own IP you can front-end them
with a single IP finally you can deliver
low latency and high bandwidth
connectivity for all your users and with
all of this you can think of Google
global load balancing as
in finite capacity so as your users in
your traffic increase it just seamlessly
scales now let's stick maybe a sneak
peek at what's inside right because
often I get asked where is the Google
global load balancer the answer is it's
everywhere it's not a single box it's
not running in a VM it's not a cluster
it's load balancing distributed across
the world and there are four key
technologies that make this happen
one software-defined load balancing -
Google's global network 3 seamless sort
of scaling and fourth is intelligent
anycast so how many of you have not
heard of software-defined networking
raise your hand ok that's great so
basically this is software-defined load
balancing which builds on the concepts
of software-defined networking now let's
look at the right as you can see there
that is what the Google's load Buc
global load balancer does if you look at
the traditional load balancer you see a
single load balancer right if you look
on the right which is the Google side of
things there is no load balancer and the
reason for that is load balancing is
done by distributed software-defined
entities called Google front ends we
call them GF is very lovingly and the
geophys themselves are distributed
across the world and they want they work
in conjunction with a number of other
software-defined systems to do global
load balancing now what they really
enable you to do as you can see there at
the edge of the Google Network and you
can see a number of G Fe s so when
somebody says where is the load
balancing it's in each of these G EFI's
which are scattered around the world the
GF is enable you to terminate your user
traffic closest to your user and the
load balance the user requests to the
closest healthy back-end with available
capacity so they do work with other
software-defined systems to do very
sophisticated load balancing which is a
function of proximity and capacity so
available capacity essentially now let's
look at the second key key enabler
that's Google's global network
Google has 70 plus H pops across 33
countries and it has a high quality
private network for h2 data center
connectivity so each of these are
connected to the data center and you are
computing the data centers through this
very very high quality network now out
of these seven th pops these load
balancing Gia fees are placed in 50 of
these pops close to your users across
the globe so again as I said before if
anybody asks you where is the GCB global
load balancer the answer is it's at all
of these 50 plus flower pops across the
globe now let's look at these two
diagrams a little bit closely right
because your next question should be
sure you let me put this close to the
user what's the benefit for me look at
the left that's your traditional cloud
provider your users request is going to
traverse just the general internet for a
majority of time and finally reach the
load balancer in your cloud providers
data center now let's look at the Google
global cloud load balancing right if you
notice the Geo fees are sitting very
close to your user so the first line
which is your TCP session 1 your user
request is badly traversing the Internet
right and this means because it Travis
is the Internet for a short time beyond
that the Geo fees will make sure that
they deliver your request over Google's
high quality private network and what
does this do for you the benefits are
significant reduced latency and improve
throughput for your users delivering
unflappable services even in the wake of
stability or instability and one thing
which is not obvious which which I
wanted to point out serving gasps static
cashable contents from multiple points
near your users so why doesn't everybody
do this this way of load balancing is
not easy to architect it needs a global
network and it needs sophisticated
software and distributed technologies
and Google has been doing this for the
last 20 15 years and that's what we are
really leveraging for Google cloud load
balancing
so let's come to the third part a
question we often get asked how many vm
should have provision for my service for
that the first thing you should do is
look at your workload maybe your
business is growing fast so you need to
scale up steadily or maybe you have
bursty traffic or maybe your traffic is
on and off in nature maybe you're
running batch workloads then you come to
the classic resource allocation problem
if your provision for peak
you're wasting resources if you
provision for average you are in big
trouble right so the ideal way is to
provision in line with your traffic and
this is where Google cloud platform auto
scaling comes in it intelligently
adjusts resources based on load so if
your traffic grows so do your resources
if your traffic shrinks your resources
shrink as well but most importantly to
do this well this auto scaling does the
scale-up in a matter of seconds there is
no pre-warming needed so if there was
one takeaway about auto scaling I want
you to take that away with you now how
do you provision auto scaling so
basically you provision auto scale
instance groups and you specify an auto
scaling policy it's a very intuitive
intent based policy you say stuff like
ok keep my VMs at 85 percent utilization
now autoscaler it will monitor your
instances it will work closely with the
global load balancer and it makes sure
that if the capacity of your VMs goes
below the configured threshold it will
scale them up in a matter of seconds the
last key technology I wanted to talk
about is intelligent anycast now let's
look at this technology through the lens
of an actual deployment let's say you
decided to host www my abdominal cloud
your users are all over the world so you
put your compute instances in three
regions let's say you put them in US
central Google data centers in Europe
and then in Asia now with normally with
any other cloud provider you
would have had three DNS whips one per
region and then you would have to use
DNS load-balancing to sort of send them
to the correct region
if you've used DNS base load balances
before so like global server load
balancers I can say that confidently
because I wrote code for a lot of them
you have a bunch of issues that you have
to deal with
first of all DNS based load balancers
take minutes if not hours to detect and
react to change they also suffer from
resolver caching and other well knows
TTL based issues now if you look at it
in contrast let's look at the
intelligent anycast you have a single IP
so there is no problem with caching
wherever you go it's the same I think
what that means is Maya in California
Bob and London and then Shannon
Singapore they each use one twenty one
one one to reach your service my app
dot-com intelligent anycast
also redirects them to the resource
that's closest to them with available
capacity and there are a lot of things
that I have not put here but for
instance if they are routing flaps it'll
ensure that your request goes to the
correct place the place that can serve
it reliability and can solve it well so
your next question will be yes the
sounds great how do I get started just
go to the Google cloud platform website
and get started configuring it select
you the flavor of your load balancers or
whether you want HTTP load balancing in
this case select and deploy your
backends configure a front and any cache
web and you're done I don't know if you
can see things clearly but what I wanted
to show is a new UI that's making its
debut next month it's as simple as just
picking the first option start
configuring and then you go configuring
the three steps that we put there I
purposely didn't show you the other two
because I want to highly encourage you
to go and try them out yourself so
honestly the biggest pet benefit or the
biggest advantage that Google Cloud
load-balancing delivers is peace of mind
you can see the port on the screen right
that is one happy customer on the screen
and there are many more who would say
the same
so I highly encourage you to try it and
I'm sure it will give you the same peace
of mind as well one last interesting
thing I wanted to point out is that
Google global load balancing not only
delivers your cloud services but it's
just as essential to Google's own
services it uses the same set of
software-defined technologies and the
same global infrastructure that are
being used to deliver Google search
Gmail and other Google services so
definitely use this information when
you're trying to clinch getting your CIO
to move the workloads through the cloud
so with that it's time to see global
load balancing in action please welcome
our next speaker ana tech lead for
global load balancing to show you how to
deliver reliable services not just a
cloud scale but at not pull scale Thank
You Ana
thank you projector today we will be
looking beyond cloud scale availability
all cloud providers publish the SLA some
published 3 9 some published three and a
half miles like GCP but what if you want
to build an application that is 5 9
availabilities or even beyond that
that's how will Google build its
applications there is a short answer for
that use global load balancing the
global load balancing you get worldwide
capacity anytime anything happens you
get a protection against region-wide
failures and the cross regional overflow
and cross regional failover you're
getting highly available solution today
we're going to be working through the
example of highly available globally
load balanced service Santa tracker who
doesn't like center whether your child
an adult or in between it's always fun
to watch Santa to deliver a present and
while Santa is busy delivering presents
around the world you and I as a service
on earth will pay attention to traffic
volume and shape and get to experience a
series of disasters they typically
happen over service lifetime we will
start with configuring Santa Tracker
service on TCP with configuring it in
three continents why because service is
global and stunts of going to be
traveling around the world we will
create one instance group in Asia one
and year and two in United States to
account for anticipated traffic
unfortunately I was up all night
prepping for all talk and after playing
the main
and it instances I forgot to enable
autoscaler in Asia so much for it is
going to bite us later on as the days
start Santa is hard at work delivering
presents and while children and adult
watching him to drop presence through
the chimneys you and I looking at a
console and guess what the traffic
volume is a little higher than
anticipated in fact it is a lot higher
so on one hand we are happy that our
service is so popular on another hand we
don't know what's going to happen
do we have enough capacity to serve are
they prepared for success and indeed
interest in Santa is not lighting up and
now we have a lot of traffic incoming
and suddenly we see overflow to year
what just happened
well what happened we go back and look
at our configuration and figure out that
we didn't have at a scalar in a book so
our global load balancer saved us from
the outage in overflow access of traffic
to closest region but then without any
intervention so we go back enable
autoscaler and as autoscaler is started
instances health check and they are
ready to serve the traffic is moving
back to China to Asia serving locally
with the minimum latency as they goes by
now Santa is in Europe our instances in
here just got neo binary the support for
elvish language
unfortunately the future wasn't tested
well so the first time elves
the Santa helpers tried to test try to
check the status of Santa tracker
the binary crash don't panic nothing
happens
our global load balancer immediately
recognized the felt the health of failed
instances and move traffic away let's
stop here for a second and analyze what
just happened there are no other cloud
provider that has cross regional fail
overs and let's see whether regional
fellow world would work and it would
because all binaries within a region are
running the same version so as long as
else continue to send theory of death
the binary would continue to crash our
global load balancer another hand
practically fix number of fell over
candidates without any configuration all
it's done automatically and based on the
health size and remaining capacity it
constantly recomputes new followers
every two seconds and you look at it and
you see that lions are going a little
bit far away but what we say that even
though the traffic is moving in the US
and temporarily you're getting a little
bit higher latency it's much better that
that not being able to serve in yes
right because that's what happen should
we stay in Europe in Europe so they're
all back to the faulty binary and now
previously stable binary runs without
elvish soap or else would have to play
in English next year that
this is a second time when global load
balancing saved us from full region
outage as the day goes by
Santa's traveling and delivers present
now in America but the single load
balanced IP our users experience best
latency as users from each post comes to
the to come to the closest instance
groups and as they comes to the close
and we think Noah was done Rudolph the
reindeer went on a famous talk show and
endorsed the Santa and it also said that
why don't you go and check out our
favorite Santa tracker and sure enough
million of people's flock of a flock to
our website creating a perfect storm of
locally generated traffic they're
holding our breath what is going to
happen because there's so much traffic
that the even buffers that autoscaler
kept for extra capacity being overrun
immediately but our load balancers saves
us again
within seconds starting to move traffic
where additional capacity is starting
from the closest and then going further
way if there is not enough capacity
still in a meantime our autoscaler
grew up back up and the traffic caused
by Rudolph is moved back to us and is
now served locally and as fewer
attention moved on so did the traffic
and now we are back to our regular serve
a global obese outside save us yet again
this time from multi-region outage
after delivering president Hawaii Santa
is getting well-deserved rest and we can
look back at our long day and see what
happened global load-balancing helped us
to successfully serve huge number of ups
and averted three potential disasters in
Asia he had an errand configuration
which was mitigated by cross region
overflow and then pulling back ventra
the autoscaler group back up they
survived the crash of our European
instances and mitigated in by
temporarily rerouting traffic to United
States and in the United States with the
road out a perfect storm of locally
generated traffic by more than traffic
and deepening worldwide in a capacity
obviously I didn't talk about all cases
that could have happened and so I
encourage you to pick your favorite case
and analyze it in the presence of global
load balancer I hope this example of
running globally load-balanced highly
available service persuaded you that
global load balancer is the way to build
scalable reliable and highly available
global load balancing comment rate HTTP
lb on TCP and to further learn about
bustin class global load balancer please
welcome Matt smart that lead and manager
at Google
thanks Anna so as Anna demonstrated
global load balancing is an important
tool to improve reliability and
availability and serve your users with
low latency to even reduce further
reduce latency for your users you can
use a content delivery network or CDN a
CDN will cache your site's content all
around the world
speeding delivery to your users while
also offloading work for you from your
backends to that end the Google cloud
platform has partnered with six CDN
operators through our CDN interconnect
program with CDN interconnect you'll get
optimize connections to your CDN of
choice and pay less for network egress
and in the coming weeks we'll be
launching the beta release of Google
cloud CDN Google cloud CDN is our own
delivery network and it integrates
seamlessly with the global load balancer
we've deployed our global load balancing
stack at more than 50 points of presence
around the globe as per jacque de
mentioned earlier and it integrates with
Google cloud CDN at each of those
locations with Google cloud CDN your
cacheable content can be served directly
to your users from each of those 50
locations not only do you get a
world-class edge press
backed by the global network per doctor
mentioned your cash flow content can be
served directly to you you can partition
your site based on the backend service
to enable CDN for only those portions of
your back-end services that's highly
cashable leave off your admin api's but
use it for your static content your CSS
your JavaScript maybe those elevation
english-language files all without
hosting it on a new domain you can also
analyze how well you're doing with the
cloud monitoring which is stackdriver
integration and cloud logging so as we
saw with Santa you're gonna have you
know you're gonna have a lot of traffic
but you might not know my how much
why should you need to send test traffic
or trickles of live traffic just and
warm up your load balancers when we
created the network load balancer which
is a precursor to the global load
balancing for TCP and UDP traffic we
wanted to take it for a spin so we did
what any normal Googler would do we
threw a million queries per second at it
so global load balancing we want to do
the same thing in this case we took it
up to 1.3 million then we stopped
because now just we wanted to stop and
as you can see this is to a single
anycast address no dns load balancing
required between regions and all this
traffic is being sunk at whatever
regions like traffic is coming from in
this case we both had the sink and the
source in these three locations left
listed again no pre-warming necessary up
over down with cloud steve google cloud
CDN and global load balancing we
decrease latency in a couple of ways the
first again is by having these locations
all around the world physically close to
your users the second is by a second is
by supporting modern protocols like HP -
which reuse the network very well and
more efficiently so let's look at how
well we do this first section we've got
some your application deployed in a
single region in this case US East one
and the data is showing median load time
for 100 kilobyte files we're doing
pretty well in New York that's that
little red bar but the rest of the world
is pretty grumpy and we like the rest of
the world the second part we've deployed
our application in more regions in this
case both US regions Asia and Europe
it's gotten much better but the gold and
the green South America and Australia
they're still not quite that happy and
we want to do better
the third part we've enabled cloud CDN I
can't see what that says anymore I think
they're pretty happy now so our users
depend on Google cloud platform to
deliver resilient auto-scale services
with a global footprint we've described
how global load balancing fits into that
picture but you really don't have to
take my word for it
let's hear from a power user of gold
Google cloud load balancing please
welcome Dimitri from Wix Thank You bet
hi admit tree and solution architect at
wix.com I want to tell you how you took
and move one of our services to Google
cloud sorry it's gonna be this one so
what is weeks
but those of you who are not familiar
with the company it's easy what you see
is what you get service to building a
website so business owners even
non-technical ones can easily build the
site for the company the way they want
to see it and the platform is built up
of many services many products and
hundreds of services but today I will
only want to talk about one of them
which is image serving and manipulation
so the service itself is very simple and
basic it's exactly what it sounds like
site owner opposed an image site
visitors come and see it on the website
but we do not serve original images we
recite them adjust them on the fly to
improve user experience so if you like
open at the same website on a desktop
and mobile device you will get the same
images in different dimensions and the
numbers you are seeing here growing
month after month and just like today
snapshot so we have a big storage to
handle many requests to serve and today
I have to say will I run on active
active setup on both Google and Amazon
and I can tell you a lot about what role
differences
objective totally different talk so
let's start with some history first
three years ago we were running an three
quantum data centers this means storing
each image three times and the machines
that were doing is an image manipulation
were keeping the images in a local
storage
the downsides are quite obvious with the
gross we have we had to double our
capacity each for five months without
stopping the service moving the files
not a nice task to do don't do it please
don't and of course there is a hardware
you have to keep your maintenance going
you have controllers felling you have
did Horlicks felling you have batteries
just name it everything can go wrong so
we start moving to the cloud and it's
very beginning it was not easy many
features were missing so we had to be
very creative so what we were doing at
the very beginning we were serving the
traffic with network load balancer
through a one single region and we were
manually creating our instances
adjusting the size of our setup it means
if we were expecting more traffic to hit
we were creating just enough instances
to handle it now weeks strongly believes
in continuous integration continuous
delivery with the hundreds of services
we have even if there's no heating GGA
every couple of minutes ok
no one can predict which one of them
might affect images traffic no one we
have to be very responsive not
recommended long night so when
autoscaler arrived it just changed the
way we live change the way we do
anything it remove this need to
configure and tune things manually we
could sleep at night finally out of
scanner it's very critical part of the
system it was mentioned before but what
little synchronized like if you have too
many instances running you just pay with
extra money well if you have not lost
instances running you have paid with
your system latency you pay with your
system availability you pay with your
customers
ok
and Google Auto scanner keeps you is
just right amount of instances even in
traffic picks and it adapts extremely
fast it took us time to put trust in
outer scaler
today we know we can trust it but it
took us time I will give you just one
example that we had there were out of
skilled instance group running with
metrics below the church hold for a long
time without any image instance being
removed strange behavior so we open a
support case we like have a conversation
there's a team what we realized is that
auto scanner took care of us
removing even one single instance would
raise the traffic hitting the remaining
instances that will raise the metric
above the threshold new instances would
be created so autoscaler was smart
enough to keep us from this flopping he
escaped us safe of course also the
health checks when globally she to be
load balancer came out it finally
allowed us to start the traffic from
multiple regions we could stay up
whatever happens in any single region
was fantastic now we can control the
traffic to hit specific instance groups
and the opposite we can drain the
traffic from the others of course there
are additional pieces in the puzzle you
have deployment manager you have
preemptable VMs by the way principle VMs
are one of the reasons we prefer the
traffic to hit specifically instance
groups it's fantastic it's all easily
configurable when it goes from zero to
full scale in matter of seconds I will
give you just this small example of
traffic small weekly traffic we have you
can see the traffic goes up and down as
the day goes by I can see the amount of
instances adjust accordingly magic way
no health move move everything goes
automatically and you can see the
response time stays the way it should be
stays the way we defined it as the most
exciting things that our
look at the bottom right graph this is
traffic
spread it across 14 different instance
groups in different zones of different
regions and you can easily see one
traffic of some instance group falls
down for any particular reason
like preemptable VMs were taken from us
or we we deployed faulted version it
turns over automatically to other
instance groups and no harms to service
happens we stay up 100% so if you
haven't tried all this magic before just
do it so let me help you to projector to
summarize our things
so hi folks I'm back
and the reason I'm back is first of all
to thank Dimitri and Wix for being here
with us and you know whatever we say at
the end of the day if customers say that
it's probably much much more powerful so
that's why I wanted to here wanted you
to hear from him personally so thank you
Dimitri the reason I'm here is because
if you leave this room and I'm hoping
you do after we are done but when you
leave this room you leave at four key
takeaways first our global load
balancing is software-defined load
balancing for cloud scale it uses
state-of-the-art software-defined
technologies and distributed systems
technologies along with of course
Google's global network the second one
is you can deliver your services across
the globe with a single anycast
front-end web you will not find this in
any other cloud provider third it will
deliver high performance low latency and
seamless scaling or are the seamless
auto scaling for all your services and
lastly you can optimize your delivery
across the globe using three things
cloud CDN CDN interconnect and of course
Google's global network that enables all
of this so with that I think we come to
the end of it free feel free to get any
one of us if you have any further
question and with that let's conclude
and say scale on thank you
you
you